it's a day that ends in why and so the
libs are attempting to promote yet
another weird sex thing having already
succeeded at convincing people of a
dubious new definition of marriage and
the possibility that a man can become a
woman and the health benefits of onism
the libs are now focusing their
rhetorical skill on persuading us all of
the moral good of
orgies the latest issue of New York
Magazine takes up the challenge as the
magazine explains quote the new issue
explores the world of ethical non-
monogamy brief
digression if you have to describe
something specifically as ethical it
probably is not ethical non- monogamy is
a contradiction in terms it is like a
vegan lion or elderly babies if the
adjectives and the nouns contradict one
another then you have a classic leftist
expression this is a rhetorical trick
the libs use all the time undocumented
American is a classic example of that
there is no such thing as an
undocumented American because the reason
that said undocumented American doesn't
have documents is because he's not an
American so the phrase is contradictory
New York Magazine goes on quote the
package includes a feature by Allison
Davis on one specific polycule and
offers poly curious readers an in-depth
guide to opening up their relationships
an in-depth guide the libs are not just
detailing the degenerate behavior of
weirdos they are actively trying to get
you to try it too but they know it's
degenerate no matter how many times they
Jam that word ethical in there they know
that this behavior is repulsive and
disordered and the proof of that is that
the cover image on the magazine is a
bunch of
kittens cute little kittens
an accurate portrayal of polyamory would
depict sad girls with daddy issues and
brain fried sers so why kittens it's the
same trick that they pulled when they
appropriated the rainbow the libs always
appropriate cherished symbols and then
they use them to their own disordered
ends because the reality that they're
pedaling turns people off so they lure
you in with lies and by the time you
become aware of the nasty reality they
have already moved on to their next
disorder ordered lust I'm Michael nolles
this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
show welcome back to the show who's
Trump going to pick for VP the vep
stakes are on and it's not just idle
chatter and guessing Donald Trump Jr is
floating some possibilities some of whom
are really great and some of whom are
absolutely terrible so I hope Trump
picks a good one we'll get to that in
one second first
though it it I was going to say it
wouldn't be a week of the Michael N show
now I think it might have to be it
wouldn't be an episode of the Michael N
show if we didn't just briefly touch on
some more of the weird sex stuff that
the libs are pushing it's not me guys
it's not me I if I had my brothers we
would never talk about weird sex stuff
on the show at all it's not I'm not the
one that that put the the orgies on the
cover of the big lib magazines I'm not
the one telling husky dudes to go into
the girls bathroom I'm not the one
changing the definition of marriage the
libs are doing it they're the aggressors
in the culture War I'm just noticing it
I'm just observing it and and making a
comment on okay but I this is not my
choice all right they're the ones
pushing it on us and
and most
egregiously once they do all of that
once they push their weird sex stuff
they then try to pin it on
us I guess that's not the most egregious
part probably the most egregious part is
when they destroy marriage and you know
cast Ray kids and but just after that is
when they try to pin us for it kind of
like when nor McDonald said about
hypocrisy you know it's not the worst
but it's it's bad the FBI has just
arrested a I've been alone so long but
this time I'm
grer with you so look the guy's
obviously completely insane I I'm not
trying to suggest that he's you know a
left-wing political philosopher many of
whom are insane themselves but it it
seems like a little bit of a stretch
right for the FBI to call this person a
right-winger a an alt-right far-right
terrorist I I it's crazy this isn't the
first time that the FBI has done this
late last year there was a gang of
pedophile satanists that had been doing
all sorts of horrible things to girls
and they arrest one of the guys and they
say he's a white supremacist the guy's
Hispanic and he called the judge in the
case of cracker but it and we'll get to
why that is in just one second first
though speaking of important matters of
life and death you got to go check out
trust and will right now go to trustand
will.com noes from maintaining control
of your assets to easing the burden on
your loved ones an estate plan can
ensure your fam is prepared and
protected if you're looking for a way to
set up your estate to offer Financial
benefits and more then you need to check
out trust and will traditional estate
planning can cost thousands of dollars
and many one-size fits-all solutions may
not capture all the important details of
the life you've built with trust and
will you can protect your legacy from
the comfort of your home starting at
just 159 bucks they have simplified the
process of creating and managing your
will or Trust online from finding out
what's right for your family to
finalizing documents with a notary I am
very very Pro will I have had a will
since I was 17 or 18 years old it's
really important it will give you peace
of mind it will make sure that your
stuff doesn't go to the state it'll make
sure your kids don't go to the state
it'll it'll take care of all the things
that matter material and even more
importantly your family and your kids
don't don't leave that burden to the
loved ones behind and and don't leave
them vulnerable to the state each Willer
trust is crafted to be State specific
and customized to your Needs Trust will
will cover your care wishes Guardian
nominations final Arrangements power of
attorney with thousands of fivestar
reviews on trust pilot trust and will
has earned an overall rating of
excellent secure your assets and protect
your loved ones with trust and will 10%
off plus free shipping of your estate
plan documents by visiting trust and
will.com 10% off in free shipping at
trustand
will.com a would be Mass shooter
according to the FBI far rightwing
extremist a uh satanic pedophile
[Music]
gang led by a Hispanic who called the
judge in the case of cracker he's a he's
a white supremacist what and the white
supremacists obviously they lumped in on
the right why what what's this about
I'll tell you exactly what it's
about the terrorists have to be
right-wing they have to be they can't be
leftwing because the leftwing that's the
good side so they have to be right-wing
the Li are the goodies and the
right-wingers are the
baddies so they're going to figure it
out they're going to make it in this
white people are the baddies too so the
hispanic guy becomes white just like the
the man who killed Trayvon Martin George
Zimmerman he had to be white they find
out the guy looks as Hispanic as they
come it looks like he just got off a
boat somewhere from Latin America
doesn't matter he's a white guy now
because he's a baddy so he has to be a
white that's just the way it is people
who try to make sense of this they start
from the facts and then they try to get
to the conclusion that the left has come
to that's not how it works the left
starts from the conclusion and they work
backwards and they will rewrite a
person's race they will rewrite a
person's stated political views they'll
rewrite a person's sex and sexual
identity if they have they'll rewrite
anything the end has to be the same now
speaking of right-wingers we're into the
vep stakes baby there are still two
maybe more two even somewhat
registering additional Republican
candidates in the primary Beyond Donald
Trump that's Nikki Haley and Ronda
santis I think ASA Hutchins is still in
it I think there's another guy named
Binkley in it but you know they're
they're not really showing up anywhere
des santis and Haley are barely
registering for all intents and purposes
the primary is over so now we're moving
on to who is Trump going to pick for his
running mate Donald Trump Jr has some
thoughts could you see your father
running with Ron de santis I asked him
that question over the summer and he
didn't rule it out could you see R how
do you it's hard you know people do that
like you know I I I would do whatever I
could to make sure it wasn't Nikki Haley
but uh you know but like aronda Sanz
could I see you're never going to rule
out someone that is you know a leading
Contender it doesn't mean that's who you
go with I could see other people that
would be great I'd love to see you know
a JD Vance I'd love to see a Tucker
Carlson I'd love to see you know people
who are just principally uh you know in
alignment as well as like aggressive I
you you actually need a fighter the
Republicans in Washington DC are weak
you can have the house the Senate and
they'll still roll over it doesn't is
your dad serious about Tucker Carlson
are those rumors serious I would you
listen that's clearly would be on the
table right I mean they're they're
they're very friendly I think they agree
on virtually all of these things they
certainly agree on stopping the
NeverEnding Wars uh and so you know I I
would love to see that happen and you
know that that would certainly be a
contender I love Tucker Tucker would be
a cool choice
I'm fine with it I don't think it's
going to happen though the reason I
don't think it's going to happen is I
see no evidence that Trump would pick a
huge personality who in any way could
even somewhat compete with Trump's huge
dominant personality I don't see any
evidence of that at any point in his 40
plus year public life certainly not from
the last pick the last pick he made was
to balance him out a quieter guy from
the Midwest who's on board he's going to
be supportive but he's not going to
really challenge Trump or overshadow him
he's not going to have had public
disagreements with Trump very often as
Tucker has so you know love Tucker very
conservative guy that'd be terrific but
I don't really see that
happening the next choice Elise
stefanic don't like that Elise stefanic
is pretty liberal she's from New York
the reason that some are reporting that
she's being considered for VP is she's
been relatively loyal to Trump which is
good that's a good thing you you really
want someone who's going to be loyal she
wouldn't overshadow Trump in any way uh
but I still don't really see what she
brings to the
table she's a liberal
Republican who's totally identified with
Team Trump so even if Trump were trying
to do a Reagan Bush kind of thing here
you know you get the conservative guy at
the top of the ticket and the more
establishment liberal guy at the bottom
of the ticket here the at least stepanic
doesn't really unite the party because
she's lumped in as a Trumper it's just
kind of like the the worst of all worlds
from an electoral
perspective the the more liberal
policies but but also the baggage that
goes along with supporting Trump if you
hang out with the country club
establishment set so and she's from New
York I mean it's not like Trump's going
to carry New York I don't really see it
happening uh DeSantis would be great I
mean love D santis absolutely great
Governor that can't happen because
constitutional
uh you can't have a guy at the top and
bottom of the ticket from the same state
it would it would uh not work with the
electoral college system so you know
just as a tech I'm not I don't think
Trump would pick to santis anyway for
the same reason I mentioned above with
Tucker I don't think he's going to pick
a a really tough personality who's got a
career of his own who might butt heads
with him I just don't see that happening
but
uh certainly not someone who's
campaigned against this has become a
pretty nasty primary but there's also
just a technicality so I don't really
see that happening it's funny Don JR
says I really hope it's not Nikki you
know if Nikki is hoping for a Reagan
Bush kind of thing um that's the path
forward for her but if the Trump family
is against her and they think this has
gotten too personal and they can't trust
her then then she's out so that leaves a
really interesting choice there JD Vance
JD Vance is on the team he got elected
with amazing major endorsement from
Donald Trump he represents more the new
right the more populist more
traditionally conservative side of the
party as opposed to the alternately
libertarian side or the neoconservative
side or the globalist side you know JD
does not represent that he's also from
Ohio and they they would always say as
goes Ohio so goes the nation Ohio
accurately has predicted a lot of
presidential elections that predictive
power failed in 2020 but the Democrats
rigged it in 2020 and changed all the
rules hopefully the rules will have been
corrected a little bit by the time we
get to November 2024 of the choices that
were just floated there JD is probably
the best one what do you think what do
you think let me know in the comments
I'm curious as far as how things stand
right now
though the question is not barring a
lightning bolt from the Democrats or
from the heavens uh Will trump be the
nominee he he is no one else has a path
to Victory the question is how long will
this drag on for so next up we go to New
Hampshire and what we've been hearing is
that Haley is surging in New Hampshire
she's way ahead of DeSantis but she's
still pretty far behind Trump 10 to 15
points behind Trump uh that that lead
seems to have widened the last number I
was looking at was Haley about about 10
points behind Trump Now new poll out
from St anel shows Trump at 52 so he's
cross that 50% Thresh told every other
candidate could unite he would still
beat them and he's 14 points above Haley
who's at 38 DeSantis at
6 now uh among Republicans who are
voting not just Independents New
Hampshire Republicans they're a little
bit weird you know they're independent
they cut their own course they don't
really reflect the National Party among
Republicans Trump is up over Haley by 40
points it's 65 to 25 and then among
Independents Haley has a lead over Trump
but it's only a 15 point lead so it's
not not enough to cover for the the 40
points Haley 52 Trump 37 so there's the
anom poll there's also a suffk poll
shows basically the same numbers Trump
at 50 Haley at 36 so that same 14-point
lead Des santis at six so far this
season I'm a skeptical of the polls
sometimes especially in general
elections as anybody the polls have have
proven accurate that that was a big
lesson out of Iowa the polls here are
consistent so DeSantis certainly going
to get completely destroyed in New
Hampshire he's not even campaigning in
New Hampshire though DeSantis has sent
his campaign staff to South Carolina
that might be kind of a last stand what
disantis is hoping for here is that
Haley gets blown out of the water so
that it it doesn't just look like a
two-man race between Trump and
Haley if Haley somehow pulled out a
miracle in New Hampshire and won she
still wouldn't have a shot at the
nomination but she could drag this thing
out a little bit longer and she has an
incentive to drag this out a little bit
longer CU she's a young woman so she can
gobble up a little bit of Leverage she
she won't have a ton of electoral votes
by the end of this process she's not
even on the ballot in Nevada she's going
to get blown out in Michigan that's all
before super Tuesday she's going to get
destroyed on super Tuesday but she knows
that she's a very smart politician I
don't think that what she's trying to do
here is force a Reagan Bush situation I
think she's trying to be the number two
from 2024 so that when 2028 rolls around
Nikki Haley can say I almost got it last
time and whether Trump wins or Trump
loses she can say I'm next up appoint me
which is how the Republicans used to do
this they did it with George HW Bush
they did it with Bob Dole they did it
with John McCain they did with Mitt
Romney and I think that's what Nikki
Haley is playing for here if she can
just stay in the race long enough to
clearly be the number two then she's got
a better play for 2028 uh DeSantis
has both more and less of a reason to
drop out speaking of contradictions at
the top of the show meaning Trump isn't
going to pick him for anything I think
that relationship has been blown uh
DeSantis is going to be term Limited in
Florida so he's going to be out of
office by the very beginning of 2027
it's going to be tough for him to run in
2028 especially with this showing so so
if you're Ronda santz you've raised $200
million why not just stay in you know
why not just stay in and just wait to
see if a lightning B hits trump it it
doesn't look all that great but what
else is he going to do you know there's
there's a lot of stick there's a lot of
punishment that this guy's received on
the campaign there's not a lot of carrot
right now to get out other than he
doesn't want a humiliating loss in
Florida but Florida's not up all that
soon there are still a few states to go
there in any case any way you slice
it trumps the nominee
barring a a major natural disaster or
you know Hillary showing up in the
Groucho glasses in the FedEx truck with
a silencer on her pistol barring that
Trump is the nominee lady Ballers is the
hilarious story of how a group of male
losers who can't win against other men
decide to identify as women and join a
women's basketball league yes it's
absurd it's ridiculous it's laughable
which is just another word for
ridiculous they're they're synonyms they
mean literally the same thing well it's
happening right now in the world here's
a quick look at what is being called the
most triggering movie of the decade by
us leftists are losing over lady
ballings nothing's changed this movie is
a straight up and intentional
transphobic hate crime what I see you
the lady Ballers movie needs to be
banned I'll cancel you I get the blinds
please to 11 the most toxic BS you've
ever seen you're a Monster yeah next
level hate spe Beach propaganda that's
it that's the pitch watch the most
triggering comedy of the
decade lady Ballers streaming
exclusively on Del wire plus do not wait
watch lady Ballers I joked earlier I
said that it's called the most
triggering movie of the decade by us
yeah that was in our trailer but look at
all the great reviews we got on Rotten
Tomatoes jumped up to the biggest
streaming movie in the country and all
of this when Hollywood does not want you
to see it so go check out the movie
Hollywood couldn't make it we did it
watch it exclusively on daily wire plus
right
now speaking of major election issues
Mass migration continues to be a major
issue this has been a major issue now
for almost a decade in its recent form
and it's cropped up over the years but
especially in recent years in America
obviously it was a big part of the Trump
win in 16 in the UK in Italy in Hungary
in Poland in all over Europe all over
the west mass migration is a big problem
the Dems still don't get that
message I think Joe mansion and John
fedman are the two Democrats in the
entire country who realize that just
opening up the borders and flooding the
country with foreigners is not maybe
necessarily the most prudent idea the
rest the rest of the Dems are insisting
that open borders and mass migration is
not only a good thing but it is
profoundly essentially American here we
have Democrat Congressman Max
Frost to my colleagues on the other side
of the aisle let's be honest with
immigrants who deserve better than what
you're offering them don't welcome
immigrants if you plan to reject them if
you keep pushing your bigoted hr2 bill
then also pass this bill I've taken the
liberty of drafting it for you it
removes the Statue of Liberty our
largest symbol that tells people to come
here this is who you are removing the
fabric of America so I want to know
which Republican who supports and voted
for hr2 will introduce this bill the
Statue of Liberty doesn't actually tell
foreigners to come here certainly
doesn't tell them to come here in in
violation of our laws certainly doesn't
tell them to come here illegally and and
in infinite numbers but it doesn't tell
them to come here at all the Statue of
Liberty is a beacon of light to the rest
of the world
it is to
illuminate and provide a model for the
rest of the world the Statue of Liberty
is not a statue of Atilla the Hun
tearing down our borders it's not a
statue of genas Khan conquering our
country it's a Statue of Liberty I'm not
even all that hot on the Statue of
Liberty I mean don't forget it was given
to us by the French the French and not
even the good old aristocratic Catholic
Revolution French who are totally nuts
Who sacked churches and replaced the
traditional religion with with temples
of reason and chopped up all the
neighborhoods and made them all really
dumb and gave us the metric metric
system and just all just G was a gift
from them so I you know I like it I'm a
New Yorker I like the Statue of Liberty
but it does not mean what he says it
means the reason this guy thinks that
the Statue of Liberty tells foreigners
to flood into country in violation of
our laws is because there's a poem on
the Statue of Liberty called what's it
called the Great Colossus I think it is
it's by Emma
Lazarus it was it was a poem added on
put there at Ellis Island in
18 889 or something it was latter part
of the 19th century this woman Emma
Lazarus was a socialist she was Tech
actually specifically a georgist which
is a forgotten political economic
program but it's just a version of
socialism and yeah yeah I'm sure that
some
weirdo socialists in the 19th century
wanted to make a French statue even more
radical but that is not in the American
tradition oh and by the way guess what
happened about 30 to 40 years after we
got the Statue of Liberty and even we
put the poem there we severely curtailed
migration for half a century that's what
we did we instituted the Immigration Act
of 1924 and we severely curtailed the
number of immigrants who could come into
the country we tied it to to National
and ethnic quotas and we totally
excluded Asians okay so it's pretty
restrictive I'm not I'm not suggesting
that any Republican is calling for a
return to that but don't tell me that it
totally undermines American history we
we have had from the very beginning of
our country very very severe
restrictions on immigration for much if
not most of our
history okay it's not
the country is not what these people say
it is for goodness
sakes now speaking of restoring order
Florida legislators are doing great
stuff they are seeking to ban the pride
flag in government buildings and schools
love that the legislation would would be
broader it's not just targeted at the
rainbow and pretty soon I guess we'll
have a polyamorous flag they'll just add
a new some new little Strife to the Pol
to the to the rainbow flag I don't I
wonder what it will be I don't even
think I want to imagine what it will be
the legislation would qu uh require that
quote a government entity may not erect
or display a flag that represents a
political Viewpoint including but not
limited to a politically partisan racial
sexual orientation and gender or
political ideology
Viewpoint that's great because what that
does is it says you can't do the Rainbo
stuff you can't do the BLM flag you
can't do any of your weirdo Flags this
is
great why wouldn't we do that why
wouldn't we pass that No No One Believes
that today you could uh erect a a Nazi
flag on an American government
building right no no one seriously
thinks that you might say well if we
don't let you put the Nazi flag up what
you're curtailing free speech uh not
really not really No One Believes it no
it's not it has no place in a government
building you can't put every single flag
on a government building and flags are
symbols and what they symbolize is
supposed to tell you something about the
The Entity that is Raising those flags
and in this case it's the government so
it tells you something about your
country and our country is not a Nazi
country and it's not a communist country
like the BLM people would have it be and
it's not yet Sodom and gomorah so maybe
it is I don't know we're veering close
to it but but I don't think it's quite
that yet it's America it's America to
that congressman's point when he says
you know the Statue of Liberty welcomes
us all here from the very beginning of
America we were we were supposed to be a
model for the rest of the world to
emulate not to empty out the rest of the
world and fill up our country a model of
Christian charity by John Winthrop it's
one of the most famous speeches goes all
the way back to the 17th century it's
one of the most famous speeches in
American history it says we're going to
be a shining City on a Hill it's a light
it's a model for people they can see it
and so what are we modeling are we
modeling BLM Marxism are we modeling
degenerate sex stuff or are we modeling
what what are we modeling I want to
model truth justice in the American way
at the very least and maybe maybe things
even better than
that so now now we turn from fake
matters of free speech to legitimate
matters of free speech this is a story I
wanted to get to yesterday I have to
mention it
here Jordan Peterson has been sentenced
to a re-education
camp
Jordan he he lost his appeal and so
Jordan will lose his professional
license if he does not go to a
re-education camp and all I can think
is that poor re-education
Camp can you imagine those poor
instructors the poor bureaucrats it's so
sad I feel so badly for
them that guy is not going to go quietly
into that into that night no no I hope
he films it be great my favorite comment
yesterday is from KW 91 who says
completely missed the opportunity to
call the Davos people wsts shame on you
Michael that's really really good K w91
and I'm going to steal it we finally
arrived at my favorite time of the week
when I get to hear from you in the
mailbag our mailbag is sponsored by peer
talk go to peer talk.com kwes save an
additional
50% off your first month take it away
good morning Michael this is Arun today
I've got a fun question question for you
now I think I speak for all conservative
Americans when I say that I've never
fully understood the leftist racial
hierarchy nevertheless I'm going to ask
you for some insight on this matter as
we are all aware the left has a strict
policy against the portrayal of
so-called people of color whatever that
term means by people of Caucasian
descent yet a couple months ago an SNL
sketch of one of the early GOP debates
flagrantly violated that rule and even
now as the primaries seem to be drawing
to a swift close with the consolidation
of the field around Donald Trump SNL has
suffered no social consequences from
this I'm referring of course to the
portrayals of Nima Nikki Haley and vram
Swami who are both Indian in the
aforementioned SNL sketch Governor Haley
was cast as a white female whereas Mr
ramaswami was portrayed by a black male
now personally this doesn't offend me
and I think SNL is free to cast any real
life character using an actor of any
race as long as an actor vaguely
resembles their real life counterpart at
least in terms of height build or other
relevant characteristics I'm glad they
at least chose actors of the appropriate
sex but could you dissect this for me
and explain why it is that Governor
Haley is mapped onto a white person
whereas Mr ramaswami is mapped on to a
black person is it really as simple as
the fact that Governor Haley is of
slightly lighter skin pigmentation than
Mr Rami or is there a deeper social
commentary that you can offer here thank
you as always for bringing a modum of
Sanity to these insane times excellent
question Arun as always three answers
come to mind
one they get away with more when it
comes to Republicans they can mock
Republicans in a way that they're not
allowed to mock Democrats so that's
that's the easiest part the second part
is the colors match you know Nikki looks
white and V looks much Browner so the
colors match and the libs have drawn a
distinction recently between race and
ethnicity and these terms are really
malleable you know that the meaning of
the word race has changed over time and
ethnicity has added in there and culture
and race have become more separated in
in um modern anthropology but all these
things overlap quite a lot and when the
libs say race they're referring to color
and when they say ethnicity they're
referring to I don't know dissent of a
of a different sort uh so that's that's
how they do it but then the third one I
think is important you don't want to
look over it which is Indians don't
really count for them the livs don't
really like Indians they'll
sometimes defend Indians and get
offended on behalf of Indians you saw
this a little bit uh with the Babylon B
headline very funny headline it said
Donald Trump offers v ramaswami a
position running the White House
7-Eleven it's a good headline and V
thought it was funny but a bunch of
white people got offended on V's
behalf sometimes you see it but broadly
the libs don't really like Indians
because the Indians upset a lot of their
um um plans and and schemes Indians are
extraordinarily
successful uh they tend to be very smart
and high achieving
academically um they uh can can be a
little bit more right-wing obviously the
Indians elected a right-wing leader
who's been governing for the better part
of a decade now over there so uh they
don't really like that the Indians
become a pro the South Asians become a
problem for the libs and so they're
further down the hierarchy even though
they are in fact foreign and brown next
question hello once again Mr nlls it is
slap my base coming at you with another
question so I have been tasked to come
up with a funeral mass as I need to
prepare one for a relative who will be
passing on very soon and I wanted to ask
you what are some of your favorite
funeral hymns other than Amazing Grace
which is basically the staple I've
already got a couple in mind but I
wanted to see what you would think of as
a good preference and maybe I can add it
to the catalog once again thanks for
everything great
question I tend to prefer even more
traditional than say Amazing Grace or
something like that so my first go to
would be a Maria Schubert's a Maria
maybe box a Maria maybe brahms's a Maria
even who knows um another a that would
be good would be a verum corpus would be
nice
uh but it sounds like you want something
a little bit more modern it's considered
old by a lot of modern people but I
consider a little bit more modern like
Amazing Grace so it depends if you want
something a little bit more modern or
even a little bit more Protestant How
Great Thou Art I really like really like
the Elvis version oh Lord my God in
Humble that's a good one
um but I I like the old sturdy
traditional hymns you know uh oh Jesus
we adore thee oh Jesus we adore thee who
in thy love divine I I I find that good
for a funeral
because a lot of modern funerals just
look back with sadness on the loss of a
person a loved person and then they
either openly despair or they just fall
into soft soap about how well we know
that person is in heaven now even though
we don't know that for certain we we
hope that that person's in heaven we
pray that that person is in heaven but
we don't know
so it it comes off as soft soap and
Wishful Thinking rather than a
persuasive truth I I prefer and I hope
everyone take note by the way you know I
hope I live a good long life but when my
requium Mass is to be said I want good
solid hymns and I want them preaching
the gospel and that's what I want I
don't want sentimentality about me I
want good
sturdy gospel and good sturdy hymns
about Jesus and the reason I want that
is because that gives you real
hope if all of that's true if the
religion is true if Jesus is who he says
he is if God is real then we can
actually have hope that there is
something beyond death but if it's not
then we're all just going to be
despairing no matter how much we fool
ourselves a windy answer to a simple
question next one I Michael love the
show thank you for continuing the
conservative fight I'm wondering if you
share Congress woman tb's concern that
Trump incited an erection on January 6th
thank you and I appreciate your thoughts
H I think you're confusing Congress lady
TB with Congress lady premila jaipal uh
but I am concerned that Trump excited an
erection on January 6th I know he did in
the newsrooms All Over America I know he
did did among all the democrat congress
people I know he did I think plus Adam
kinzinger and uh Liz Cheney but I repeat
myself uh yes no it does concern me I
find it very unsettling and unpleasant
to think about but but Trump did it
there's no there's no question about
that hello again Mr nles is slap my base
coming at you with another question so
as you obviously know the year in review
for 2023 in cigar fish andado has just
been released the Arturo Fuente Opus X
ended up winning top cigar of the year
so my question to you would be have you
been approached yet by Cigar afficionado
to review Mayflower cigars and if you
did do you think this would change the
perspective of sales if the review was
either good or bad now I referen this
magazine for all of the cigars that I
would like to try and obviously with you
being my favorite podcaster Mayflower
kind of spoke for itself
so I would like to know would it be a
problem if cigar ficado gave you the
review or would be this be something
that you would be openly looking forward
to in order to see what the
professionals quote unquote think thanks
great question I I would like to be
reviewed in cigar afficionado I actually
have a copy of it right over there I'm a
longtime reader of cigar ficado so I I
would like to be reviewed in it because
I love the magazine I I don't actually
need cigar ficient Auto to review it
because I'm already selling a lot of
cigars uh so not not boasting here it's
just that uh a a lot of new cigar Brands
need the magazine to get on anyone's
radar and because we're coming from
daily wire we sell out instantly I mean
we've we've
sold all the cigars that we possibly
could I think the number is
57,000 in the the equivalent of like 3
days or something and so we're producing
as many as we can I actually just had a
meeting
earlier today about the cigars um but
we're going to get many many many more
so we want to have so many supply issues
but for me it would be nice to get
officient AOS ratings because I I
respect those guys I really like the
magazine it would be very cool the great
success of Mayflower Cigars has been the
Fulfillment of a 15E long dream and so
that'd be kind of fun too because I've
been reading the magazine for that long
but uh no the people I need to make my
Cigar Company successful are you all and
you have already done that and made the
launch of Mayflower cigars arguably the
most successful cigar brand launch ever
certainly certainly up there written
question from John hello Michael I'm a
longtime listener of the show first time
writing in so forgive me if I'm asking a
question you've already proposed what do
you think is keeping the body positivity
movement and the gender affirming care
for youth's movement from clashing with
each other Dylan wow great question
um
you're thinking of the logic I this ties
into something we were talking about
earlier in the show you're thinking of
the
logic supposed logic in those respective
ideologies and
movements first you got to think of the
end goal first the leftwing thinking is
very consequentialist they think about
the end result they want to achieve and
they think that any means justifies that
even if the various means that they use
contradict one another what the libs are
doing with both the gender affirming the
movement and the body positivity
movement is attacking normality normal
standards of beauty and health and truth
so either way gets them there promoting
really unhealthy Lifestyles and
appearances that are grotesque that will
get them there and uh chopping off kids
genitals and castrating them and
pretending dudes can be chicks will get
them there too I I totally see your
point that the gender affirming care is
actually contrary to accepting your body
as it is and loving yourself and all the
rest of it um but to to be as charitable
as I can to the libs what a lot of it
comes down to the most coherent argument
for what they're doing is just a a
radical kind of
subjectivism where they say well I look
like a man but I think I want to be a
woman I think I'm a woman so I just am a
woman because I I say so and you can't
tell me otherwise well you know I'm 400
lbs and I haven't taken a walk in in 10
years and I'm doing all sorts of
unhealthy things that will harm me but I
I like it and I get to pick whatever I
want because my will is all that matters
totally divorced from reason and so
that's the nearest thing they have to a
coherent argument for it but really what
it's about is they just they just hate
normality probably because they have
Daddy Issues if I had to guess um next
question from Dylan Michael what's the
most lib thing you do mine is that I
shamelessly enjoy coconut and oat milk
beat that o oat milk no come on don't
don't do that it's not even good for you
some of the lib things are are somewhat
healthy for you oat milk is bad for you
it's just like sugar don't do that most
lib thing I do I don't know I do a lot
of lib things right I mean things that
are are
today associated with the left I don't
know I like Opera I play the
ukulele
I I go to Starbucks going to Starbucks
is probably the most Li thing I do but I
don't care it's a great Corporation
they've effectively
installed public restrooms in every city
in the world and a lot of small towns
too the coffee I think is quite good and
yeah maybe that's it that's maybe that's
the most lib thing that I
do because on the cultural stuff that I
do that today is branded lib but it it
in the past it would have been branded
conservative you know like being
interested in poetry or something is
kind of considered Li today but it would
have been quite conservative actually
even manly you know back in the day uh
but the Starbucks thing would always be
kind of Li and I do it and I that's what
can I say I don't even apologize sorry
I'm not sorry I'm Michael this is the
Michael N show see you next
[Music]
week